case you haven't heard the new trend
from certain schools is the ditch
homework and the ditch the deadlines in
favor of what's called Equitable grading
this teaching strategy removes
traditional grading and attendance and
extra credit all meant to equal the
playing field for kids who may face
hardships at home that's the way it's
explained Constantine kison is the
author and host of the trigonometry
podcast about you
good morning good morning good to be
here so um what do you take the Merit
and throw it out the window because I
was looking at this from Las Vegas
California Iowa to Virginia it appears
to me that if you're a talented student
and you're smart you will no longer be
challenged if you have nothing to do
after school that's right and some
people have used the war on Mary and I
think this is what this is forget about
the intentions you have to look at the
outcome and the outcome is you're
training kids to do things that are bad
for them in the long run right that's
what's happening here so if you continue
to educate children in this way and this
is where as an outsider I can say this
like I'm from Russia originally they're
not doing this in Russia they're not
doing this in China they are trying to
get their maths and engineering and all
of those things to be as good as
possible because they understand the
world's a competition but if you
continue to go down this path well what
does that mean for the United States
what does that mean for the West more
broadly so I think we should all be
concerned about it silver lining though
growing up in the Soviet Union we had
this sort of indoctrination and ideology
being rammed down in everybody's throat
but your parents could teach you not to
buy into it so I think this is a thing
where as a parent you have a job to
inoculate your children as much as
possible and the good news is if you can
teach them that life is about
competition life is about winning life
is about being better they're going to
crush in the current environment because
everybody else has been told that you
get a medal for nothing right actually
we saw that in a Fox News poll that we
had came out just last night in
questioning problems with schools and
parents are saying book Banning is a
concern of theirs 56 said that too much
focus on race at 51 and transgender
qualities policies at 49 and parents not
having enough say at 48 I'm curious you
mentioned the Soviet Union but you also
have so much experience in the UK is
this a problem for Western Civilization
or is it just the U.S is on I know no no
well I always say to people in America
you know everything you flush down the
toilet we get for breakfast the next day
so this is what's happening I mean this
ideology is spreading around the world
uh the Western World dangerous in
particular and that's why those of us
who are not in the United States are as
concerned about it as you guys are
because we know it's coming and to a
large extent it's already infiltrating
our society so everyone should really be
focused on it I think that first point
you made is well taken because the
parents can fight back against this yeah
and your your reflection on growing up
in Moscow not as Russia again Soviet
Union okay yeah was it the parents at
home could say don't listen to the
garbage yeah absolutely that's what my
parents it's the first opening section
of my book I talk about the conversation
that my parents had with me and then
they said you're about to go to school
you don't get to say all these things
that are problematic right very familiar
I think to people nowadays don't say
anything because you're gonna cause
problems did you ever get in trouble at
school oh I got in trouble all the time
I mean look at me but but that I've just
made a career out of it going forward
but also the parents would have a
conversation with you and they'd say
they're going to tell you this this and
this and this is all Bs and don't buy
into it yeah wow so do you think that
should happen here I'm hundred percent
but the good thing about the United
States is you can get involved right and
I think you can run for the school board
you can talk to other parents parents
can actually organize and go do we want
this to be taught to our children of
course it's easier said than done but I
think you have more scope to to push
back against some of the stuff hold up
the book so everybody can see it's
called an immigrant's love letter to the
West what's your main message in it uh I
think the West is good and I think we
should preserve it and stop beating
ourselves up about it dig it great to
meet you thanks for having me spend more
time see you we'd love to all right
thank you take care so um what do you
take the Merit throw it out the window
because I was looking at this from Las
Vegas California Iowa to Virginia it
appears to me that if you're a talented